AC 360 STARTS NOW.
>>> IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
EVIDENCE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S JANUARY 6th
INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN HEATING
UP, TIME FOR OVEN MITS.
JOHN BERMAN IN FOR ANDERSON.
CNN HAS JUST LEARNED THE DOJ HAS
SUBPOENAED MORE THAN 30 PEOPLE
IN RECENT DAYS INCLUDING SOME
VERY BIG NAMES IN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S ORBIT.
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY NEW
DEVELOPMENT TONIGHT.
THERE'S ALSO A BIG ONE IN THE
FIGHT OVER DOCUMENTS SEIZED FROM
MAR-A-LAGO.
CNN'S SARA MURRAY JOINS US WITH
THE VERY LATEST.
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING ABOUT
THESE NEW SUBPOENAS?
>> WELL, JOHN, ME AND A WIDE
RANGE OF COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS STORY ALL DAY
AND HAVE LEARNED THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS SUBPOENAED MORE
THAN 30 PEOPLE, PEOPLE IN THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S ORBIT.
PEOPLE LIKE BILL STEPPIAN,
DONALD TRUMP'S FORMER CAMPAIGN
MANAGER, DAN SCAVINO THE FORMER
TRUMP CHIEF OF STAFF.
THESE ARE WIDE RANGING SUBPOENAS
SEEKING THINGS THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH THE SAVE AMERICA PACT,
DONALD TRUMP'S FUNDRAISING AND
POLITICAL VEHICLE, INFORMATION
RELATED TO THE FAKE ELECTOR
SPOT, ANY INFORMATION HANDED
OVER TO THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE,
A NUMBER OF THEM SEEKING
DOCUMENTS SOME ALSO SEEKING
TESTIMONY.
WE ALSO LEARNED IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" TONIGHT THAT
INVESTIGATORS APPEAR TO HAVE
GONE ANOTHER STEP FURTHER WITH
SOME WITNESSES INCLUDING BORIS
EPSTEIN AND MIKE ROMAN THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" REPORTING BOTH MEN
HAD PHONES SEIZED.
CNN HAS NOT INDEPENDENTLY
CONFIRMED THIS.
IT IS A SIGN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S INVESTIGATION IS
INTENSIFYING PARTICULARLY AS
THEY ARE ABOUT TO HEAD INTO THE
QUIET PERIOD AHEAD OF THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
>> CERTAINLY WIDENING.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM
AND THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
HAVING TO DEAL WITH THE FBI
SEARCH OF MAR-A-LAGO?
>> WE KNOW THAT THERE IS THIS
CONTINUING FIGHT OVER THE
SPECIAL MASTER WHO MIGHT BE
NAMED TO OVERSEE THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTS THAT THE FBI SEIZED
FROM MAR-A-LAGO.
WE LEARNED EARLIER TODAY THE
TRUMP TEAM IN A COURT FILING
BASICALLY SAID WE DO NOT LIKE
EITHER OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S CANDIDATES FOR THIS
JOB.
THEY DID NOT OFFER AN
EXPLANATION AS TO WHY THEY
DIDN'T LIKE ANY OF THE
CANDIDATES THE DOJ PUT FORWARD.
WE ARE LEARNING IN A FILING
TONIGHT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
IS TRYING TO I GUESS OFFER SOME
SORT OF AN OLIVE BRANCH PERHAPS.
THEY SAID THEY ARE OPEN TO ONE
OF THE CANDIDATES, THE FORMER
TRUMP TEAM PUT FORWARD.
THIS IS A RETIRED JUDGE, SOMEONE
THEY SAY BELIEVES HAS THE
EXPERIENCE, THE RELEVANT
EXPERIENCE WITH THESE KINDS OF
DOCUMENTS AND THESE KINDS OF
ISSUES TO POTENTIALLY OVERSEE
THAT.
NOW THIS IS GOING TO GO TO THE
JUDGE, JOHN.
WE'LL WAIT TO SEE WHAT SHE SAYS
ABOUT THE SPECIAL MASTER
CANDIDATES AS WELL AS THE
GOVERNMENT'S PREVIOUS REQUEST
THAT THEY EXCLUDE 100 CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS FROM THIS SPECIAL
MASTER REVIEW.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SARA MURRAY ON TOP OF THIS.
A LOT OF NEW DEVELOPMENTS AND
WE'LL HEAR MORE AS THE WEAK
PROGRESSES.
PERSPECTIVE FROM GEORGE CONWAY A
CONSERVATIVE LAWYER AND "THE
WASHINGTON POST" CONTRIBUTING
COLUMNIST.
YOU SERVED AS DEPUTY ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY GENERAL DURING THE
GEORGE W. BUSH ADMINISTRATION
AND CURRENTLY TEACHES LAW AT UC
BERKELEY.
I WANT TO START WITH THE NEWS WE
BEGAN WITH THE IDEA THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS TAKING THE STEP OF
SUBPOENAING MORE THAN 30 PEOPLE
IN THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S ORBIT.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
THEIR INVESTIGATION?
>> I THINK IT TELLS US EXACTLY
WHAT JUDGE GARLAND SAID HE WAS
GOING TO DO WAY BACK ON THE
FIRST ANNIVERSARY OF JANUARY
6th, WHICH WAS THAT HE WAS GOING
TO FOLLOW THE FACTS AND THE LAW
WHEREVER IT MIGHT LEAD AND HE
WAS GOING TO, THEY WERE GOING TO
DO WHAT THEY DO IN A LOT OF
LARGE CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS AS
THEY WORKED THEIR WAY UP TO THE
TOP OF THE PYRAMID.
AND IT'S BEEN A MASSIVE AMOUNT
OF WORK THAT THEY HAD BEEN DOING
SINCE JANUARY 6th IN PROSECUTING
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE ACTUALLY ON
THE GROUND AT THE CAPITOL.
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
WHO WERE THERE.
IT IS ALSO A MASSIVE JOB TO
FOLLOW UP AND GO HIGHER AND THAT
IS WHAT THEY'RE DOING NOW,
REACHING THAT STAGE OF THE
INVESTIGATION EXACTLY AS JUDGE
GARLAND SAID HE WOULD.
>> CLEARLY, VERY BUSY.
GEORGE, I ALSO WANT TO ASK YOU A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THIS BACK
AND FORTH BETWEEN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S LAWYER HAVING TO DO THE
SEARCH OF MAR-A-LAGO.
THERE ARE SOME LEGAL ARGUMENTS
BEING MADE BY TRUMP'S LAWYERS
AND ONE OF THEM IS THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HASN'T PROVEN
THAT THE DOCUMENTS SEIZED ARE IN
FACT CLASSIFIED.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
ARGUMENT?
>> AGAIN, IT IS A FUNCTION OF
THE CONCEPT THAT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES CANNOT
SOMEHOW ACT LIKE THE MAGNIFICENT
AND HOLD DOCUMENTS AND DECLARE
THEM DE CLASSIFIED.
THE STATUTES THAT WERE INVOKED
TO SUPPORT THE SEARCH WARRANT
DON'T REQUIRE CLASSIFICATION AND
THE SUBPOENA WHERE THEY PRODUCED
DOCUMENTS AND FAILED TO PRODUCE
THEM ALL BACK IN THE SUMMER
REQUIRES THE PRODUCTION OF ALL
DOCUMENTS WITH CLASSIFICATION
MARKINGS WHETHER IN FACT THEY
REMAINED CLASSIFIED.
IT IS COMPLETELY IRRELEVANT AND
IS BASED UPON A PRESUMPTION.
>>> WHAT ABOUT THE FACT THAT IN
THAT ARGUMENT TRUMP'S LAWYERS
NEVER ACTUALLY ASSERT TRUMP
DECLASSIFIED THE DOCUMENTS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> I THINK ACTUALLY BOTH SETS OF
PAPERS ARE TRYING TO REACH SOME
KIND OF COMPROMISE BY PAPERS I
MEAN BOTH THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
YOU SAW THE NEWS THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS AGREED TO
ONE OF THE SPECIAL MASTERS AND
IS ONLY SEEKING AN EXCEPTION
FROM THE SPECIAL MASTER ORDER
FOR ABOUT THE 100 OR SO
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
COVERED.
THEY ARE AGREEING TO STOP THE
USE OF ALL THE OTHER
NONCLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN THEIR
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
THAT IS AN INTERESTING OLIVE
BRANCH FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
ON THE TRUMP SIDE I WOULD SAY
THERE IS AN OLIVE BRANCH THERE
TOO.
THEY ARE NOT REPEATING SOME OF
THE CLAIMS IN COURT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS ALLIES
ARE MAKING THAT PERHAPS
PRESIDENT TRUMP DECLASSIFIED THE
DOCUMENTS.
IT DOESN'T SEEM SO.
YOU LOOK AT THE FACTS RECOUNTED
IN THE COURT PAPERS AND IT
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE PRESIDENT
TRUMP OR HIS AIDES ACTED LIKE
THE DOCUMENTS WERE DECLASSIFIED.
BOTH SIDES ARE TRYING TO DIAL
DOWN THE HEAT AND MAYBE REACH
SOME KIND OF COMPROMISE.
>> ONE POSSIBLE REASON YOU DON'T
PUT IT IN A COURT DOCUMENT THAT
TRUMP DECLASSIFIED THEM IF IT
TURNS OUT NOT TO BE TRUE THERE
IS A SANCTION THERE.
ANOTHER ARGUMENT I WANT YOUR
TAKE ON IS THE TRUMP SIDE IS
SAYING HE HAS AN ABSOLUTE RIGHT
OF ACCESS TO PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS HERE WHETHER CLASSIFIED
OR NOT.
DOES THAT MATTER?
>> I'M NOT PERSUADED BY THAT IN
THE PAPERS.
IT IS NOT A QUESTION ABOUT
ACCESS TO THE PAPERS BUT WHO IS
THE REPOSITORY OF THE PAPERS.
PAST PRESIDENTS WANT ACCESS TO
THEIR PAPERS TO WRITE MEMOIRS
BUT THAT DOESN'T ANSWER THE
QUESTION OF WHO HOLDS THEM.
TRADITIONALLY IT IS THE ARCHIVES
WILL HOLD THEM AND THE
PRESIDENTIAL LIBRARY THEN GIVE A
COPY TO THE PRESIDENT SO HE OR
SHE CAN ACCESS THEM.
>> THERE IS NO RIGHT TO KEEP
THEM IN THE HOUSE.
YOU HAVE ACCESS UNDER THE SAFETY
AND CONTROL OF THE ARCHIVES.
NOW THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS
SAID ONE OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S CHOICES FOR SPECIAL
MASTER TALKING ABOUT JUDGE
RAYMOND DEERY IS APPROPRIATE.
DOES THAT MAKE JUDGE DEERY THE
ODDS ON FAVORITE TO GET PICKED
HERE?
HOW COULD THIS PLAY OUT?
>> THE JUDGE CLEARLY HAS A
DISCRETION TO PICK WHOEVER SHE
WANTS.
I THINK IT WOULD MAKE SENSE TO
PICK JUDGE DEERY AT THIS POINT.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS SO MUCH OF
AN OLIVE BRANCH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WAS EXTENDING BY
ACKNOWLEDGING JUDGE DEERY'S
ACCEPTABILITY.
JUDGE DEERY IS A WELL RESPECTED
JUDGE IN THE EASTERN DISTRICT OF
NEW YORK AND BROOKLYN, WELL
RESPECTED FOR DECADES.
AND HE SERVED ON THE FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SURVEILLANCE COURT.
THE COURT THAT HANDLES FISA
APPLICATIONS AND IS FULLY
QUALIFIED TO REVIEW CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AND HANDLE IT.
SO HE IS ACTUALLY A GOOD CHOICE.
I THINK THE ONLY REASON THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DIDN'T AGREE
IMMEDIATELY IS BECAUSE THE TRUMP
PEOPLE VOTED THE NAME SIX HOURS
BEFORE THE FILING DEADLINE AND
HASN'T RUN IT UP TO THE FLAG
POLE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TLFRJTS ARE STILL
SERIOUS ISSUES TO BE WORKED OUT
WHEN IT COMES TO THE SPECIAL
MASTER.
WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE BIG ONES?
>> YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THERE ARE STILL A LOT OF ISSUES
TO BE RESOLVED.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT LEGAL
ISSUES IS THE ONE THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT ON THE SHOW BEFORE,
DOES PRESIDENT TRUMP AS THE
FORMER PRESIDENT HAVE ANY KIND
OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, THE
RIGHT TO KEEP SECRET DOCUMENTS
AND COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS OR HER TOP
AIDES FROM THE INCUMBENT
PRESIDENT?
THIS IS AN ISSUE WHICH THE
SUPREME COURT FLAGGED EARLIER
THIS YEAR WHEN IT OVER RODE
TRUMP'S CLAIM OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE AGAINST THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE.
IT IS AN ISSUE THE SUPREME COURT
ITSELF ALSO FLAGGED BACK IN THE
NIXON CASE IN THE 1970s, THE
GOVERNING LAW FOR ISSUES WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
I'M NOT SURE TRUMP WINS ON THAT
ISSUE.
I WOULD BET HE DOESN'T.
I STILL TEND TO THINK THE
INCUMBENT PRESIDENT DECIDES
WHETHER THERE IS EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE OR NOT BECAUSE THERE
IS ONLY ONE PRESIDENT AT A TIME
AND IN THIS CASE THE PRESIDENT
IS CARRYING OUT HIS OR HER
DUTIES TO EXECUTE THE LAWS, YOU
KNOW, THE PROSECUTIONS.
BUT TRUMP CAN DELAY THINGS
SEVERAL WEEKS IF NOT MONTHS BY
TRYING TO RAISE THAT ISSUE AND
DRIVE IT ALL THE WAY TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
>> GEORGE, VERY QUICKLY, THE
TIMELINE HERE.
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT JUDGE
CANNON IS GOING TO SAY BUT IF
SHE DOESN'T DO SOMETHING TO
SATISFY THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND THEY APPEAL ALL OF THIS, HOW
LONG WILL IT PLAY OUT?
>> IT'S HARD TO SAY.
I MEAN, IT COULD BE RESOLVED ON
STAY APPLICATIONS WHICH COULD BE
DONE VERY QUICKLY OR IT MIGHT
REQUIRE FULL APPEALS.
I WOULD HOPE THAT THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO STAY THE PORTION OF THE
ORDER THAT THEY ARE SEEKING TO
STAY, WHICH IS THE RESTRICTION
ON THEIR ABILITY TO USE THE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THE INVESTIGATION.
BECAUSE THERE IS REALLY NO BASIS
TO SEPARATE WHAT THE JUDGE IS
ALLOWING, WHICH IS THE USE OF
THE INFORMATION FOR
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE PURPOSES AND